[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT JOHNSTON:
I'm Scott Johnston.
I'm on the Hangouts team.
Thanks for coming
to this session.
We're going to talk
about team communications
and how we've been thinking
about them in G Suite.
I think that one of the early
questions when we started
working on Hangouts for
productivity and for teams was,
what really makes
a successful team?
And you may have seen us publish
within Google a study called
Aristotle, where we followed
teams over many, many years
and looked for what
characteristics really
made a successful team.
We've done that with our
G Suite customers as well.
And that's really
where we started
in terms of getting
to the heart of what
tools do we need to provide
teams with to make them better
teams.
And really to make a team of 300
function like a team of three.
And so one of the core--
there's a number of takeaways--
well one of the key
ones for me was really
that there wasn't a lot of
commonality between work styles
or particular behavior
of the teams in terms
of being highly
communicative or not so,
or having a certain
set of personalities
or having a key mix
of personalities.
But really in the
end the foundation
of the most successful
teams that we
found when we did
research was that it
was driven by experiences.
So their foundations were what--
the foundations were the
base of how they interacted.
And those came
through in that they
were able to have
emotional interactions.
So they were able to connect
at a level that was usually
outside of work.
They had-- they could have
complex conversations that
were often heated and
intense, and people
felt safe having those
kinds of conversations.
And everyone seemed to
have a mix of work styles.
And so they needed tools that
supported those work styles.
They had a great deal of control
over deciding when you were
going to work and
when you weren't.
Excuse me.
And so that really was at the
foundation of the products
that we built, both from
Jamboard through to Hangouts.
And then the other thing
that we just have seen,
and I don't need
to tell you this,
is just this
proliferation of tools
that we can use now
to be productive.
And the more tools the better.
But at the same time people
were jumping between and having
trouble staying in the loop.
Even something as
simple as a spreadsheet
to track something
going on requires
us to go to that spreadsheet.
And there's a
cognitive step there.
And that takes time.
And so we really
needed to figure out
a way to take communication
and span it across an ecosystem
maps, not just create a new
home that people would go to,
and think that would
solve the problem.
And so what we
announced this morning,
for those of you who
weren't at the keynote,
is a rebuilt Hangouts.
And there are really two
components of team productivity
that we focused on.
One was the virtual
room within chat.
And then the other was meetings,
face-to-face meetings being
key, getting you into meetings.
And there was a session earlier
today, maybe some of you
made on Hangouts Meet.
But what this session
is going to talk about
in a bit more
detail is really how
we rebuild Hangouts chat, the
focus on team productivity.
There were really
three key principles
that we were working with.
One was this ability to focus.
And there's a couple different
aspects around focus and teams.
One is your ability to turn
off whatever communication tool
that you're using so
it doesn't bother you,
and you can focus
and get into flow.
But also, even within
the communication tool,
we knew we had to
figure out a way
that, especially in real
time communications,
a way to allow people to have
conversations that didn't
interrupt other conversations.
And we've all seen this
in consumer chat tools,
where conversation will get
woven and fragmented, really.
You'll be deep in
one conversation,
and another person will
bring up another topic.
And that fragments
the conversation
and often is very
frustrating to users.
So we had to figure out a
way to get a form of focus
on the ability to drill
into a particular topic
without interrupting others.
Expression was key.
And this is linked to what
I was talking about earlier,
around teams really
needing to be
able to connect at
an experience level
and at an emotional level.
And then the other core part was
connecting the different tools,
bringing them into the same UI.
And then automation was core.
And that really--
I know we talk at Google a
lot about machine learning,
but automation actually starts
earlier than machine learning.
Which is-- even our own
products, for example,
take way too many
steps for you guys,
for you folks to do things.
If you're in a six person
meeting, creating a Docs file
and sharing it with
those six people
is way too many steps right now.
And so there's a
coarse automation focus
we needed to have to
start to automatically do
things that require too
many steps right now.
And that's just a simple
computer science problem, not
a machine learning problem.
But we knew we needed
to start there.
And that's where, when you look
at some of what we talked about
this morning around the Meet
agent that automatically
schedules things for you,
that's what that's about,
is how do we eliminate
as many steps
from your day as
possible, so you
can focus on the work at hand?
Like other products
in G Suite we
knew we had a strong
focus on the enterprise.
That's everything from
security to scalability.
And scalability doesn't
just mean classic fan out
and ability to handle
a lot of users,
but also the ability
to really work
within an organization
in a scalable way.
And so what you'll learn
about Hangouts Chat is
that the structures of it can
be wired up to Google Groups
or connected to central
identity systems
such that you can
have rooms configured
around specific teams
and departments,
such that you're not
dealing with this giant pile
of discussion rooms.
But instead it's divided
into topical areas
that are relevant to your team.
And what that means
is that you can
scale across an enterprise
and not just work
in a small business setting.
Accessibility is core to
everything we do in G Suite.
And so that's the foundation
of everything in design
from the very beginning.
Reliability, ease of
use, these are things
that are just part of our DNA.
And so we're going to talk now--
we're going to bring up Mike,
who works within
the Hangouts team--
and we're going to walk
through a more detailed demo
of Hangouts chat, just
to dive into details
beyond this morning.
MIKE SORVILLO: MIKE: Cool.
Thank you guys.
We all know there's
this perfect process
that you'll put in place for
a new idea, new products,
a new project, but never goes
the way you want it to go.
It's always a bit more organic,
a bit more unstructured.
And we're going to show
you how a team at Tegu Toys
uses the new Hangouts
Chat to plan a new product
and get it out to the market.
So can we switch to
the demo, please?
Perfect.
So the first thing
you'll notice is
we have a brand new web UI we
just built from the ground up,
completely dedicated to
just a chat interface.
So just like Hangouts today,
we have direct messages
where you can talk one
on one with somebody.
Right now I'm
talking with Mandy.
She put a-- we're just having
a conversation about some
of the existing toys.
And I mentioned that I
have a new idea for a toy
that I want to work on.
So one of the main things we've
added to the new Hangouts Chat
are rooms, the ability to
centralize conversations
around projects or teams.
So instead of actually--
thanks, Mandy.
Instead of actually having
a conversation right
here with Mandy, I want to bring
Varun into the conversation
as well.
And I want to create a
room for this new project.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go down here,
click the Add button,
and create a new
room for the project.
I'm going to add Mandy and
Varun to the room itself,
and put a Google doc in the
room that talks a little bit
more details about the project.
Now all I have to do to
bring Mandy into the room
is just at mention
her, and Varun as well.
And right away they're brought
into the room and ready to go.
The new Hangouts Chat also
lets you add Google Groups
as members.
So if you use Google
Groups to manage identity
across your whole
company, you can
reuse those same groups
to deploy Hangouts Chat
to your entire organization.
The other thing you'll
notice is that I just
pasted a Google Docs link.
We have deep integration with
Google Drive and Google Docs.
So any link you post
will automatically
get a beautiful thumbnail
rendered right in line,
so everybody can quickly
get back to files,
in addition to the
fact that we changed
the file permissions to
automatically match the room.
So everyone in the
room can have access.
And we remove the mundane task
of requesting access and giving
access, so people could just
start working immediately.
So this right now,
this is what we
like to call the seed
of the team, right?
We have an idea.
We have some content.
We have some people.
We have some conversation.
And the thing you'll
notice is, we didn't
need to bother IT about this.
We didn't need to
say hey, can you
please create an
email alias for us?
Or hey, can you
provision something new
on our on-prem filer for us.
We just got together,
started working immediately.
And you can see right now,
everyone's busy at work.
Mandy's putting a bunch
of stuff into the chat.
She put a projection
spreadsheet into the chat.
Varun's putting a Gantt
chart into the chat
for how we can actually get
this project moving forward.
And we recognize that when
you're working on projects
you're going to be talking
about different things.
So one thing you'll notice
is that rooms are threaded.
We let you separate
the conversation
and keep context around
different things.
So the conversation about
the projections spreadsheet
can be separated from the
conversation about the Gantt
chart.
And threads are not just
great for separating out
different topics
within it, but it also
helps separate the unimportant
chitchat that happens,
like where do you
want to go for lunch,
or what movie did
you see this weekend,
from the important work.
Now these threads are not
meant to feel heavyweight.
They're not meant to feel like
something you need to manage
or you need to organize.
We don't want to put
work on the user.
So the way they work is whenever
a new thread gets updated, it
bumps down to the bottom.
And you'll get notified.
And you'll be able to see all
the things you haven't read.
So over time what
ends up happening is,
all the important discussions
bubble up to the bottom.
And all of the
unimportant stuff,
or the stuff that's
been resolved,
just kind of floats into the
ether of the chat history.
So you'll see right
here that there's
a bunch of conversation
going on with Mady and Varun
on the Gantt chart.
And I'm sure everyone
in the audience
has experienced this before,
where you text a friend,
they text you back, you text
them again, they text you back.
And eventually you're
like OK, please just stop.
Let's just talk
on the telephone.
This is taking forever.
So we recognize this happens
at work all the time as well.
So what we've done is we've
deeply integrated Hangouts
Meet into Hangouts chat.
So when I want to just
stop the chat conversation,
I can click this
button down here
and insert a video meeting,
write a little note.
Post it into the chat room.
And now a video
meeting was created.
With one click I could
jump into the meeting.
And I'm put into a green room
where I can see how I look,
see who else is in the meeting.
And then I can jump
into the meeting.
And you'll notice Mandy's
in the meeting right now.
And we could get started.
So this is Hangouts Meet.
Like Scott mentioned
earlier, hopefully you guys
caught the session earlier.
We talked about it a little
bit at the keynote itself.
Oh, everybody left.
We talked about it at
the keynote itself,
so I'm not going to spend a lot
of time talking about it right
now.
But at a high level,
specifically designed
with enterprise use in mind.
So a completely new code base.
Less code means
faster CPU speed,
better performance, and
specific enterprise features,
like one click to present, the
ability for non-Google Apps
customers to dial
into a meeting,
and the ability
for people to dial
in on the road with a
dial-in telephone number.
So we were able to take this low
bandwidth conversation in chat
and move it to a high bandwidth
conversation with video
and resolve it very fast.
So some time has
passed, and I want
to add Nicole to this project.
So I'm going to do that on the
new Hangouts Chat mobile apps.
Can we switch to the
[INAUDIBLE] vision please?
Great.
So-- wonderful.
So I have to do, like
before, when I want
to add someone to the meeting--
to the room, excuse
me, is I just
need to at mention
them to bring them in.
So we'll type Nicole's name.
I'll add her.
Acknowledge she's going
to be in the room.
And now she's brought
into the room.
And this is where
rooms really shine.
So when you onboard
new employees,
there's always a ramp
up period, right?
You need to tell the new
employees what they should
be reading, what
everybody's working on,
the way your team works.
You know they spend
some time rifling
through some outdated filers,
looking at stale documents that
really are kind of irrelevant
and don't even matter anymore.
But the great thing
about this now
is that Nicole's in this room.
She can see the most
recent conversations.
She could jump right into the
most recent conversations.
And she could see all
the files as well.
And the most recent
ones are probably
the most relevant ones as well.
And like I mentioned before,
because we have deep Drive
integration, Nicole already
has access to these files.
So we don't need to
retroactively give her access
to the files, which is great.
So over time this
room becomes very
much like a
centralized team hub,
a team repository, where all
the important conversations
you have live, all the files
you've shared live as well.
So we've indexed all that and
made it completely searchable.
So when I want to
search, just click
on the little Search button.
And we know through all of our
Drive research and our Gmail
research, you can never
remember the file name
of a file someone
shared with you,
or ever remember the
subject line of an email.
But you always have those other
little nuggets of information,
like who sent the file, or
what kind of thing they sent.
So while you can
search for keyword,
what we've seen in
our trusted testers,
many people actually just search
by person or search by type.
So when I want to, I can
get back to that document
that I just posted earlier
and the room itself.
Cool.
Can we switch back
to demo, please?
So we know that with chat apps,
notifications can be a problem.
So we want to make sure
you don't feel like you're
working all the time.
We have very granular chat
controls, to let you dial up
or dial down the notifications
to as much as you want.
So if you want to be in
the loop all the time,
you can say, send me everything.
But if you don't, you
can just say OK, only
notify me when I was
specifically mentioned.
Someone was trying
to get my attention,
so you know it's a good
time to write back.
And not only that,
we have notification
controls at the
thread level as well.
So when there becomes a
really unwieldy thread that's
a little noisy, or
maybe a thread that
is a little bit not
even relevant to you,
like perhaps I don't care
about this Gantt chart,
all I have to do is just
mute this thread right here.
And now I will no longer
get any notifications
in that thread at all.
So let's fast forward one year.
These colored blocks,
they're in the market.
And we are working with a bunch
of other tools to help us.
And with these tools,
we've integrated them
using the Hangouts platform.
So they're actually
in the chat UI itself.
So let me switch
over to the sales
leads room, just
to give an example.
So our team uses Zendesk
for high touch distribution
partners.
So these are folks that
are really important.
And we want to know whenever
there's an issue with them,
so we can forward their
ticket and respond promptly.
So Zendesk has
built a Zendesk bot
that notifies people whenever
a high priority item comes in.
So you can see right here
that something was posted.
A high priority ticket
was created from ToyMart.
And the issue is that
a bunch of people
are returning this specific toy
set because parts are missing.
So we need to fix that.
And we need to rectify
the situation with them,
so they can be happy.
So right away Patrick just
said, can you take this,
and forwarded that
over to Scott,
so he can take it
and jump on it.
Our team also uses
ProsperWorks CRM
to keep track of
current customers
and prospective customers.
So I'm going to switch
over to ProsperWorks now.
This is our sales pipeline.
So you can see all of the
opportunities that we have,
and broken up into all the
different stages right now.
We just had a pitch with
Dinosaur Hill Toys in New York
City, and the pitch
went really well.
So they said they're
going to carry the color
blocks in their store.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to move this Dinosaur
Hill Toys from presentation
into contract sent,
because that's
the stage it's in right now.
So we've moved it.
And now when you go
over to the Chat UI,
you'll notice in real time
the notification was posted,
saying Dinosaur Hill Toys
was changed from presentation
to contract sent.
And now anyone could
start commenting on this.
Like Mandy just said--
I think that's fireworks, right?
So Mady just posted
some fireworks.
Varun called me a superstar,
which is very sweet.
So I could do that in real time.
And not only do we want to make
it so third parties can push
things into the chat
UI, we want to make it
so users can actually pull
data from third parties
into the chat UI as well.
So when I want to find out
what my sales numbers were
last month, all I have to do is
talk to the ProsperWorks bot.
And it'll write
back, letting me know
that I closed a total of $4,300
worth of sales last month.
So can we switch back to
the presentation, please?
So we're teaming with
a number of companies
to build bots on the
Hangouts Chat platform,
from a number of
business functions.
So regardless of if you work
in sales or marketing, customer
service, HR, the tools
you use every single day
will be even more useful
to you in Hangouts Chat.
Can we switch back to
the presentation, please?
Demo, sorry.
So not only can you work
with these other third party
services, we allow you to easily
build bots using Apps Script.
Which means that you can
write very custom workflow
specific to your
company, and deploy them
to your entire domain.
So you can do things
like, perhaps you
have a ticketing system
that's just custom
internal to your company.
You could write a bot that
lets the user submit tickets
straight from the chat UI.
You could deploy it to all
the users in your domain.
So on day one they can
use it without having
to go to another external tool.
So we also use the
chat platform to--
the Hangouts platform, excuse
me-- to build our own bots.
So like Scott mentioned
earlier, we demoed the Meet bot
at the keynote.
And the Meet bot uses natural
language processing and machine
intelligence to automatically
schedule a meeting for us.
So I'm going to switch over to
the Launch Coordination room.
And I think Mandy is going
to show us how it'll work.
So she asked the Meet
Bot to find a time today.
And it wrote back with a card.
Now there's actually a lot
of really intelligent things
happening here.
The Meet bot understands
things like today, tomorrow,
next week, next month,
two months from now.
It understands when
people are on vacation,
when people are in the office.
It understands what time
zones people are in.
So if I have a meeting
with someone in Zurich,
we're not scheduling that
meeting at 11:30 PM for them.
You can do other things,
like reschedule the meeting.
So Mady moved the
meeting to tomorrow.
It looked at the calendars.
It rescheduled the
meeting to tomorrow.
It supports other
commands in the future,
like canceling the meeting,
adding additional people
to the meeting,
meeting right now,
and also just booking a
room for you, if you want
to just huddle really quick.
We're also going to be building
other bots in the future that
are very intelligent on top
of the Hangouts chat platform,
that we're going to be excited
to share with you in the coming
months.
So I'm going to turn
it back over to Scott
to jump back into the slides.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT JOHNSTON: Thanks, Mike.
That was great.
So that's at a high
level just a walk through
of the new Hangouts chat.
And three main areas
that we focused on,
direct messages,
which we support now
in classic Hangouts,
along with Presence,
we added virtual team
rooms for huddling around
projects, teams, topics, and
a new Hangouts platform that
supports everything from
scripting with Google Apps
Script through to
intelligent bots.
Some of the key features
that we're launching
are ranged from search,
everything from free text
search to, as Mike
touched on, filtering
by people and types of
files, custom workflows
with Apps Script, Docs and
Drive integration, the Hangouts
platform itself, the
Meet bot that comes
with intelligent scheduling--
with Hangouts chat and does
intelligent scheduling,
and enterprise readiness
across the Hangouts platform.
So high level, looking at
helping you connect easily,
get stuff done, and be
ready for your enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]